l'une des histoires les plus aimées de tous les
temps qui les jeunes pas de blanche neige blanche blanche neige
prend vie dans l'
événement cinématographique de l'année je n'aime pas
regarder ces bois sire qui va là-bas
vous ne pouvez pas vous attendre à  te battre pourquoi
minuscule c'est le meilleur que tu as personne ne
doit connaître les détails ce printemps
blanche neige que fais tu dans le palais
je suis une sorte de princesse j'ai un [ __ ] d'
idiot oui un peu dans un
royaume enchanté Mira Mira
qui est le  la plus belle de toutes Blanche-Neige
était la plus belle femme du
monde entier était d'accord pour ne pas être d'accord la
reine est méchante elle est diabolique où tout
est possible votre père voulait que vous
héritiez de sa foule reprenez votre royaume
bébé c'est une différence aucune façon
quelque chose de drôle est  continue
je vais épouser le prince j'utiliserai le
philtre d'amour chiot amour que suis-je censé
faire avec un chiot tu prendras tes bâtons
je vais les récupérer oh ouais nous sommes
amis sommes ennemis avec le  bandits
tu es au Queen shou  ld nous l'aidons
toujours assez bien sur elle je suis la
princesse j'ai besoin de votre aide pour vaincre la
reine lui apprendra à se battre peut être le
héros
auquel je ne peux penser pas à un plus grand groupe de
guerriers à mener au combat mais c'est
mon combat quoi
yeux blancs comme neige hé les gars vous savez que nous
avons un droit de réserve